Our next guest is a TikTok star
who has gained a massive following
because of the relatable way
that she discusses women's health issues.
And today she's joining us to share her gut reaction
on how we can all improve our gut health.
It's so true,
it's such a north star of our bodies.
Please welcome registered dietician
and intuitive eating counselor with Find Food Freedom,
Sam Previte!
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
I'm so excited to talk with you.
Me, too.
I'm so excited to also learn from you.
Like, oh God,
I fear this question
because I fear the answer.
What contributes to poor gut health in women?
Well, I hope that my answer makes you happy.
Good!
Because where I like to start with women,
is our relationship with food.
Oh dear.
So, I invite all my clients to look at,
what is your relationship with food?
Is it stressful?
Is it peaceful?
If it is stressful,
thinking about,
okay how much time are we spending counting calories,
macros, portioning out food,
cutting out entire food groups?
How many years have we spent yo-yo dieting?
Mmm hmm.
And, if we notice that we're stressing a lot about that,
we can repair that relationship with food.
And so, that's a big part of what we do at Find Food Freedom
is help our clients really make peace with food,
remove the morality from food,
remove the guilt and shame.
Guilt and shame should never be an ingredient on the plate.
So, how do we help our guts grow stronger?
And, sort of, really aid in our wellness?
Yes.
So I am a huge proponent of inclusion,
not restriction.
So thinking about,
okay, let's bring it back to the basics, right?
What are the three things that keep us alive
and thriving and functioning?
Sleep, water, food, right?
So sleep hygiene,
seven to nine hours a night, if possible.
Now, I'm 35 weeks pregnant,
so if I can get two-
You're 35 weeks?
If I can get two hours of sleep-
(Sam laughs)
My God, you should have seen me at 35 weeks.
I was like, argh!
(audience laughs)
When Drew Barrymore asks you to fly to New York,
you come to New York.
Oh my God.
But you're obviously the walking pillar of health.
This is, I mean,
really you should have seen me at 35 weeks.
I, whoa.
So, we have to think about water too, right?
Like water is found in every single cell in the body.
It helps transport nutrients,
digestion, absorption.
And then, once we get that water intake
and thinking about food.
Are we getting enough fuel throughout the day?
So commonly people are under fueling.
And what kind of food are we getting?
Can we get nutrient-dense foods
that'll help heal that gut microbiome
and really give us that good bacteria.
But, I also think that there are things out there
that can help aid in gut health and digestion.
And, those are really important.
And we've teamed up with Align Probiotics,
and you're a big proponent of their products,
especially for women.
May I ask why?
Yes.
So once we heal that relationship with food, right?
And we remove the guilt and shame,
we have our nutrient-dense foods,
we can absolutely add that probiotic supplement.
And, we mentioned TikTok earlier.
All social media,
there's a lot of misinformation out there,
especially if you look up like, #gut health.
So I'm a huge fan of brands like Align
that I can really trust,
that are backed by research.
Yes.
And they have a team of female scientists
that have really gotten together,
talked with women and said,
"Okay, how do we create this product
that's going to contribute,
to not only digestive gut health,
but also feminine health and mood balance?
I was gonna say,
it must be quite different
for a woman's body and a man's body.
Yes.
So it's nice when you feel as a woman,
'cause I want men to have their backs taken care of,
and it is nice when there's,
'cause boy, our bodies are really complex.
Look at what they're capable of doing.
Yes, it's so beautiful.
Women's bodies are so unique
and so Align did such a great job
of creating this dual-action probiotic
to really touch on all aspects of health.
That's just a really, really healthy attitude
for you to convey to everybody.
So thank you for that messaging.
(audience clapping)
We all need to hear that.
Seriously.
Thank you.
And thank you for the tip!
(upbeat music)